This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So here's the thing. This year marks the 15th anniversary of 99% Invisible, which is honestly kind of hard to believe. If 99% Invisible were a person, it would be old enough to have a provisional driver's license in some states. Or celebrate a Kintaniera. That's kind of all you can do at age 15 in this country. But still, the first episode of 99% Invisible, was released on September 3, 2010. And since then, we've had 15 years of stories about design, architecture, and the choices we make that shape our world. 15 years of taking the time to stop and read the plaque.
这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。情况是这样的。今年是《99%隐形》开播15周年，说实话，这真让人有点难以置信。如果《99%隐形》是一个人，它在某些州都已经到了可以拿临时驾照的年龄了。或者举行成人礼。在这个国家，15岁时差不多也就只能做这些了。不过话说回来，《99%隐形》的第一期节目是在2010年9月3日发布的。从那以后，我们制作了15年关于设计、建筑以及那些塑造我们世界的抉择的故事。15年来，我们一直抽出时间驻足阅读那些历史纪念铭牌。
15 years of you, our listeners, sending us the most incredible observations about the built environment that we never would have noticed on our own. To mark this milestone, we thought we'd do something a little different. Instead of our usual deep dive into one particular design story, I'm going to answer 15 questions submitted by our listeners and the staff about the show, about the field of design, and about me. And to help me navigate this whole thing, I'm joined by 99PI producer Vivian Lay, who will be moderating the questions. Hi, Roman. Happy birthday. Thank you so much. I'm a little nervous, but I think we'll get through this together.
15年来，你们——我们的听众——给我们发来关于人造环境的最不可思议的观察，而这些是我们靠自己永远不会注意到的。为了纪念这个里程碑，我们觉得应该做点不一样的。不同于以往对某个特定设计故事的深入探讨，我将回答由听众和员工们提出的15个关于节目、设计领域以及我个人的问题。为了帮我顺利完成这一切，99PI的制作人维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）加入了我的行列，她将主持这些提问。嗨，罗曼。生日快乐。非常感谢。我有点紧张，不过我想我们会一起度过这一关的。
Yeah, yeah. I mean, granting me the power to choose these questions was a very bold move on your part. So we'll see how this goes. We got a lot of fun questions. Some of them were submitted through email. Some came through social media, our Discord server. Oh, nice. And a bunch of them I just made up because I thought it'd be really funny for you to answer on Mike. So, yeah, I'm ready to jump in if you are. I am ready. Let's go for it. Okay, great. So the first question came from Taylor from New Jersey. Shout out to New Jersey, my second favorite state. But Taylor actually has kind of a doozy of a question for you. They ask, a city hires you to make their residence lives 10% better without spending any money. You could only rearrange, remove, or repurpose things that already exist. What do you do? Without spending any money? No, no. And you can't create anything. It's basically just redoing what already exists. Okay.
对，对。我是说，授予我挑选这些问题的权力，对你来说是一个非常大胆的举动。所以我们拭目以待。我们有很多有趣的问题。有些是通过电子邮件提交的。有些是通过社交媒体、我们的Discord服务器收到的。哦，太棒了。还有很多是我自己编的，因为我觉得让你在麦克风前回答这些会非常有趣。所以，如果你准备好了，我已经准备好切入正题了。我已经准备好了。我们开始吧。好的，太棒了。那么第一个问题来自新泽西州的泰勒。向新泽西州这个我第二喜欢的州致敬。但泰勒实际上给你准备了一个相当棘手的问题。他们问，一个城市雇你让居民的生活在不花任何钱的情况下改善10%。你只能重新排列、移除或重新利用已经存在的东西。你会怎么做？不花任何钱？不，不。而且你不能创造任何东西。基本上就是重组已经存在的东西。好吧。
So I have one idea. I don't know if it completely fulfills the idea of no money. But if rearranging, removing, repurposing works, I feel like all those things involve like a little bit of money, honestly. But like I think that I think the best way to make a city better would be dedicated rapid bus lanes, which I think if you have the buses and you have the lanes and you just need to paint them and like, you know, mark them, I think it kind of fulfills the mandate of the question. But that would be like regular, take every bus you have, school buses, public
所以我有一个主意。我不知道这是否完全符合不花钱的概念。但如果重新排列、移除、重新利用管用的话，我觉得所有这些事情老实说都牵涉到一点钱。不过我觉得让城市变得更好的最好方法是设立专用快速公交车道，我想如果你有公交车，有车道，只需要把它们粉刷好，你知道的，做上标记，我觉得它在某种程度上符合这个问题的要求。但这将是常规的，动用你拥有的每一辆公交车，校车、公共
transit buses, and just have a lane, have them run every 10 minutes between places that are important. You will make a city tremendously better. I don't know if it's really free, but But I also like, not to quibble with Taylor, just in general, the whole concept of like fixing stuff without money is like a thing that I find is like a weird political thing that people talk about that is like, no, we actually throw money at things that we value and that's okay. But I would throw a little bit of money at this. I think it's much cheaper than light rail and various other solutions. It really is a rearrangement of resources and the emphasis on making a city a better place. but rapid, very frequent bus routes between places would be huge. Dedicated bus lanes.
交通公交车，就留出一条车道，让它们在重要地点之间每10分钟运行一次。你会让一个城市变得好得多。我不知道这是否真的免费，但我也觉得，倒不是跟泰勒抬杠，只是总的来说，不花钱就能修复东西这个整体概念，我觉得这是一个奇怪的政治话题，人们谈论时总是说：不，其实我们会在我们重视的事情上砸钱，这没问题。但我会在这个项目上花一点小钱。我觉得它比轻轨和各种其他解决方案便宜得多。这确实是对资源的重新调配，其重点是让城市成为一个更好的地方。但是，在各个地点之间开通快速、高频的公交线路将产生巨大影响。专用公交车道。
That means like they run smoothly because there's no other cars in the lane. I think that's how I'd make a city better. Almost any city would be made better by that. Yeah, it's pretty good. So the next question is actually a voice message. So I'm going to play it for you. Hey, this is Taya from Seattle. And I'm really excited to congratulate the entire team at 99% visible.
这意味着它们可以顺畅运行，因为车道上没有其他汽车。我想这就是我让城市变得更好的方法。几乎任何城市都会因此变得更好。是的，这相当不错。所以下一个问题实际上是一条语音留言。我要把它放给你听。嘿，我是来自西雅图的泰亚。我真的很高兴向99%隐形整个团队表示祝贺。
And thank you for being such an awesome part of my life. for the past 15 years, and I'm just asking for 15 more. My question is for Roman. I'm wondering, in the time that you've been doing this, has your definition of design changed at all? And if so, how? Thanks. I always interpreted it pretty broadly, even when the show started. But I think in the beginning, when you're trying to, you know,
感谢你们在过去的15年里成为我生活中如此棒的一部分，我只希望再有15年。我的问题是问罗曼的。我想知道，在你制作这个节目的这段时间里，你对设计的定义有没有发生过改变？如果有，是怎样改变的？谢谢。即使在节目刚开始的时候，我对它的解读也相当广泛。但我认为一开始，当你试图，你知道的，
like when you're trying to sort of present a thesis to an audience, you keep it a little bit tighter with like buildings and cities and product design and flags and you know things with you know visual design and i always knew that i thought of design quite broadly and the reason why i chose the name 99% invisible and not a blank design or the design of things or whatever was because i thought that that name was so evocative and open and did to the idea of what we could include in it in terms of design. So I always thought of it pretty broadly. It has gotten more broad over time. Like when I think about like there's, I mean, I never would have conceived of the Quiet Storm episode of Christopher's like 99% invisible. But I love
比如当你试图向受众阐述一个观点时，你会把范围控制得更紧凑一些，涉及建筑、城市、产品设计、旗帜以及那些带有视觉设计的东西，你知道的。而且我一直都知道我对设计的理解相当广泛，我之所以选择“99%隐形”这个名字，而不是什么“空白设计”或“事物的设计”之类的，是因为我觉得这个名字非常具有唤起力、开放性，并且契合了我们在设计方面可以纳入的内容的理念。所以我一直对它抱有相当广泛的理解。随着时间的推移，它的范围变得更广了。比如当我想到——我的意思是，我以前绝不会想到克里斯托弗的“安静风暴”那一集是99%隐形的内容。但我喜欢
it. And I think that's, that's one of the things that's the way that my definition of design has evolved is that as the show opened up and had more people in it and more brains on it, it is evolved because of their interests. And then I'm such a fan of our staff that I just, I like to follow them wherever they go. And it comes to this as a sort of the mandate of design. And that is necessarily broadened it because there's just more minds on the show than there was before. So in that way, it's evolved. Okay. So next question. This one came from our Discord. And it was from someone with the name Y-F-N-H, catchy. Okay.
它。我认为这也是我对待设计的定义不断演变的方式之一，随着节目的开放，有更多的人加入进来，更多的大脑参与其中，它由于他们的兴趣而不断演变。而且我是我们员工的超级粉丝，我只是喜欢无论他们走到哪里都跟随他们。这就是设计的使命所在。这不可避免地拓宽了视野，因为节目中现在有比以前更多的心智汇聚于此。所以从这个意义上讲，它演变了。好的。那么下一个问题。这个来自我们的Discord。提问者是一个叫Y-F-N-H的人，挺顺口的。好吧。
So they are asking, barring the noble finicular, what's the one designed object that's fallen out of common use that you think deserves another chance? I mean, the first thing comes to mind, this is not, I don't, this is not a strongly held belief, but I think cash. Like money, like paper money? Yeah, like paper money. Like, I know that I like all. all the tools of tapping and, you know, Venmo and various things, and I get it, but I feel like
所以他们问，除了崇高的缆车之外，你认为还有哪一件已经退出日常使用的设计物品值得再给它一次机会？我的意思是，首先浮现在脑海里的——这不是，我没有，这不是一个根深蒂固的信念，但我觉得是现金。就像钱，纸币吗？对，就像纸币。我的意思是，我知道我喜欢所有的
we are going down a path of having our economy locked up by apps and things and the messiness of the economy and looseness of giving change and giving tips and paying for cash and not being banked and you know i i think that there's something that we will lose and um and and and it has potentially like big downsides down the line i think that there's a there's kind of an inherent classism and the loss of cash i think that there's um i think there's a lot of control there that i'm i'm feeling queasy about when i see when i go to a place that says they they don't accept any cash it's not a strongly held belief like And I love all the conveniences.
点击支付工具，你知道的，还有Venmo和各种东西，我懂，但我觉得我们正在走上一条经济被应用程序和其他东西锁死的不归路，而经济的混乱感、零钱和给小费的随意性、用现金支付、没有银行账户（的状态）……你知道的，我——我——我觉得有些东西我们会失去，而且——而且——长远来看，这可能带来巨大的负面影响。我认为失去现金本质上带有一种阶级歧视，我觉得——我觉得那里存在很多控制权问题，每当我看到一个地方说他们不接受任何现金时，我都会感到胃里一阵翻江倒海。这不是一个根深蒂固的信念，而且
I'm not saying that those things are bad. I'm just saying that I think there's a cost. I think there's a societal cost at risk when we lose cash completely. I think that's actually a really great answer. Okay, thanks. It's a great answer because, like, I feel like every country to when they print their own banknotes, it's something, like a little piece of artwork, you know. Oh, that's another part of it that I wasn't thinking about, but like totally. I think that, like, as much as I think our paper money is so boring.
我喜欢所有的便利设施。我不是说这些东西不好。我只是说，我认为这是有代价的。当我们完全失去现金时，我认为存在着一种社会代价。我觉得这其实是一个非常棒的回答。好的，谢谢。这是一个很好的回答，因为，就像我觉得每个国家在印制自己的纸币时，它都是某种东西，就像一件小艺术品，你知道的。哦，那是另一个我没有想到的部分，但确实如此。我觉得，尽管我认为我们的纸币太无聊了，
so awful. Like, that's the part I don't love. Like, I wish it would, we would expand it to have, like, leaders in science and art and poets and stuff on our money the way every other country in the world does and better colors and everything. You know, as a representation of kind of a civic pride, that's another huge loss. Totally a huge loss. But yeah, all around cash, like, I feel like there's a great opportunity there to, you know, to represent our, you know, our best selves. And I also just think that the openness of cash as a system is super important. And it'll be a shame if it goes away completely. So our next question came from someone named Connor Hibbs. He submitted this through email. He actually submitted two
太糟糕了。我的意思是，我不喜欢这一点。我希望它能扩展开来，把科学和艺术领域的领军人物、诗人们印在我们的钱上，就像世界上其他国家所做的那样，还有更好的颜色等等。你知道的，作为一种公民自豪感的象征，那是另一个巨大的损失。绝对是一个巨大的损失。但话说回来，关于现金，我觉得这里有一个绝佳的机会来展现我们——你知道的——最好的一面。而且我也只是认为现金作为一种系统的开放性超级重要。如果它完全消失了，那就太遗憾了。所以我们的下一个问题来自一个叫康纳·希布斯（Connor Hibbs）的人。他是通过电子邮件提交的。他实际上提交了两个
questions and cheated. I'm going to ask one questions. I'm sorry, Connor. So what is something you come across in your everyday life that intrigues you? but you haven't created a story about. Oh, I've had this longstanding desire to do a story about the brannic device. Do you know what the brannic device is? No, tell me more. Okay. The brannic device is that metal foot measuring tool that is in shoe stores.
问题，作弊了。我只问一个问题。对不起，康纳。那么，你在日常生活中遇到过什么让你着迷、但你还没有为之创作过故事的东西？哦，我一直有一种长久以来的愿望，想做一个关于布兰克测脚仪（brannic device）的故事。你知道布兰克测脚仪是什么吗？不知道，多告诉我一点。好的。布兰克测脚仪就是鞋店里那种金属的量脚工具。
Ah, yes, yes. I've always kind of loved them. I don't go to shoot stores much anymore, but as a kid, like, they're fun to play with. They're like heavy, and they're fun to put. your foot in, and they're kind of, they have an ASMR quality to them, like, you mess with them and you're measuring something. And I researched them once because I thought, like, everyone loves this thing. This is the greatest thing. And I found that the Brannock Company of Syracuse, New York, that's the only thing they've made. Like, and I think they've, they've, I don't even
啊，对，对。我一直挺喜欢它们的。我不再怎么去鞋店了，但小时候，这玩起来很有趣。它们很重，把脚放进去很好玩，它们某种程度上带有一种ASMR（自发性知觉经络反应）的特质，你摆弄它们，然后你在测量某些东西。我曾经研究过它们，因为我想，每个人都喜欢这东西。这是最棒的东西。然后我发现位于纽约州锡拉丘兹的布兰克公司，那是他们唯一制造的东西。而且我觉得他们，我想他们已经——我甚至
know, maybe 100 years. I have no idea. I can't remember the research I did on it. But they've made one thing, and that is that thing. They've made that metal thing in different, colors, I think, recently, but it's, they make with this one thing. It's called the brandic device. It's named after the founder of the company. And I'm just kind of fascinated by it. For sure. And it is, I never really thought about it. It's in every single pay less, every single shoe store. And it's, they're solving a problem that you could solve with a ruler, essentially, something that you probably already have. It does width and height of the shoe and then translates it into shoe size and stuff. It's a pretty simple thing. But it's like the fact that it is so simple.
不知道，也许有一百年了。我完全不知道。我不记得我当时做的研究了。但他们只制造了一样东西，就是那个东西。他们用不同的颜色制造那种金属东西，我想最近是这样，但他们就是用这一个东西进行制造。它被称为布兰克测脚仪。它是以公司的创始人的名字命名的。我对它简直着迷。确实如此。而且它——我从没真正想过这个问题。它在每一家Payless鞋店里、每一家鞋店里都有。而且它们正在解决一个本质上可以用尺子解决的问题，那种你可能已经拥有的东西。它测量鞋的宽度和高度，然后将其转化为鞋码之类的信息。这是一个相当简单的东西。但事实是它如此简单，
And there's like these, you know, there's new ways to kind of do it. Like they have you stand on a digital thing and they do measure your foot. I've never really done those before. But I just think that there's an elegance to it. There's like a weight to it and like a history to it that I just thought, oh, there's probably something cool here. I just don't know what it is for sure. But so in a way I can't, I could never like pitch it to the staff. I've told some people about it.
而且还有这些，你知道的，有各种新的方式来做这件事。比如它们让你站到一个数字设备上，然后它们来测量你的脚。我以前从没真正用过那些。但我只是觉得它有一种优雅感。它有一种分量感和历史感，我当时就想，哦，这里面可能有什么很酷的东西。我只是不知道到底是什么。但在某种程度上我不能——我永远无法把它推销给员工。我跟一些人提起过它。
But like I feel like I'd have to just go there and see what the vibe of those folks was like and see what their deal was. One day. One day. One day. We'll send you there one day. Great. Okay. So our next question is another voice message.
但我觉得我得亲自去那里看看那些人的氛围是什么样的，看看他们的业务是怎么回事。总有一天。总有一天。总有一天。总有一天我们会把你派去那里的。太好了。好的。所以我们的下一个问题是另一条语音留言。
It's from another Connor. About a third of our listeners are named Connor. So here's Connor. Hey, Roman. This is Connor Harrington, a long-time listener, first-time caller from lovely Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Now I'm a big fan of another pod that you made an excellent guest appearance on, blank check. So my question for you is what would 99 PI's four Facebook? favorites be if the pod had a letterboxed account. Nice. Should you explain letterboxed? I'm not on
它来自另一个康纳。大约三分之一的听众都叫康纳。所以这位是康纳。嘿，罗曼。我是康纳·哈灵顿（Connor Harrington），来自美丽的宾夕法尼亚州费城的资深听众、第一次打入电话的听众。现在我是你曾作为优秀嘉宾出演过的另一个播客《空白支票》（Blank Check）的超级粉丝。所以我的问题是，如果这个播客有一个Letterboxd（电影社交软件）账号，99PI的Letterboxd最爱四部曲会是什么？太棒了。你应该解释一下Letterboxd吗？我不在
letterboxed, but I know it. So do you know what the question's asking you specifically? I do. You do. Okay. So for for listeners who might not know, letterboxed is like a social media platform, basically, where you'll post about movies that you watched, since you can make lists of things that you just watched. And basically it's a way for like movie buffs to find each other and talk about movies and that kind of thing. It's a way to, it's a way to turn an enjoyable thing into work, as far as I'm concerned. To gamify. Yeah. Gameify is something that should be relaxing. Exactly. But yeah, it's a really, it's a really popular platform with movie buffs. And so there's something called the letterboxed four where you will basically post, what are your top four movies? And that doesn't mean what do you
Letterboxd上，但我知道它。所以你知道这个问题具体在问什么吗？我知道。你知道。好的。所以对于可能不知道的听众来说，Letterboxd就像是一个社交媒体平台，基本上你会在上面发布你观看过的电影，因为你可以为你刚刚看过的电影列清单。基本上，这是影迷们互相寻找、谈论电影以及诸如此类事情的一种方式。据我所看，这是一种把一件令人愉快的事情变成工作的方式。将其游戏化。是的。把本该让人放松的事情游戏化。正是如此。不过是的，它在影迷中是一个非常受欢迎的平台。所以有一个叫“Letterboxd四部曲”（the letterboxed four）的概念，你基本上会在上面发布：你最喜欢的四部电影是什么？这并不意味着你
think are the best movies? It's kind of what are your favorite movies. And it's become a little bit of like a Myers-Briggs personality test. So what you put in your letterbox for kind of defines a little bit your personality. So I think Connor here is asking, what are 9-9PI's letterbox for? It's hard for me to know, like, what 9-9PI's one is. I can kind of just do me, I guess, but maybe they'll give some window into 9-9PI. But I always say that my favorite movie, it's very basic. Jaws has been my favorite movie forever, because I think, It is the best buddy comedy. I think it's the best adventure movie.
认为最好的电影是什么？而是有点像你最喜欢的电影是什么。它有点变成了一个迈尔斯-布里格斯性格测试。所以你在Letterboxd四部曲中放了什么，在某种程度上定义了你的性格。所以我猜这里的康纳是在问，99PI的Letterboxd四部曲是什么？我很难知道——比如，99PI的选择会是什么。我大概只能代表我自己，不过也许这能让我们一窥99PI的端倪。但我总是说我最喜欢的电影，非常大众化。《大白鲨》一直是我最喜欢的电影，因为我认为，它是最好的哥们喜剧。我认为它是最好的冒险电影。
I think it's one of the best horror movies. And it's all rolled into one. And when you watch it over and over again, different parts of it like are emphasized and you forget about little bits. I've seen it so many times. And I'm like I'm stunned by in the beginning how much information is like conveyed about the island and the city as Brody is walking around and people are cross talking over each other. and I just love it. I love it. I really, like, my favorite movies are all kind of sprawling, you know, like with different sections that have different tones. Like, I think another one is The Godfather. Again, it's so basic. Like, I get it. Like, it's not, it's not. I'm not trying to, like, you know, surprise you here necessarily. I'm a huge Cohen Brothers guy. I think, I think, again, like, I know, like, I know. I know that. I have a hard time separating best and favorite, but I think their best and my favorite is Fargo. Again, it balances tons of tones.
我认为它是最好的恐怖电影之一。它集所有这些于一身。当你一遍又一遍地看它时，它的不同部分会被强调，而你会忘掉一些小细节。我看过它太多次了。而且当布罗迪走来走去、人们互相插话时，我惊讶于开头居然传达了那么多关于这个岛屿和这座城市的的信息。我就是喜欢它。我真的很喜欢——我最喜欢的电影其实都有点气势宏大，你知道的，带有不同基调的不同章节。比如，我认为另一部是《教父》。同样，太大众化了。我的意思是，我懂。这不是——这不是。我不是故意在这里试图——你知道的——给你惊喜。我是科恩兄弟的超级粉丝。我认为，我认为，同样的——我懂。我懂。我很难把“最好”和“最喜欢”分开，但我认为他们最好的也是我最喜欢的电影是《冰血暴》。同样的，它平衡了无数种基调。
I think it's super funny. I think it's super harrowing, and I think it tells you a lot about human nature, and I can watch it again and again. The most recent movie that I would say, the most 99PI movie, and the one that really, like, knocked me out recently is perfect days. I think that's... I haven't seen that one. Oh, it's so good. It's like Vim Vendors, who's like a classic, like, you know, indie autort type. But it's about a guy who is just making his way, cleaning public toilets in Tokyo.
我觉得它超级搞笑。我觉得它超级惊心动魄，而且我觉得它向你展现了很多关于人性的东西，我可以一遍又一遍地看它。最近的一部电影，我会说，最“99PI风格”的电影，也是最近真正让我惊艳的一部，是《完美的日子》。我觉得那是——我还没看过那部。哦，太棒了！它就像是维姆·文德斯（Vim Vendors）拍的，他是一个经典类型——你知道的——独立作者导演。但它是关于一个男人在东京清理公共厕所的故事。
And it's just, it's just the greatest. It has great music. It has a great vibe. I think it could, like, if everyone watched it, the world would be a better place. Like, it really teaches you about life and contentment. And I just, I think it's super beautiful. I mean, yeah, cleaning toilets in Tokyo set. to nice music sounds like a 99PI episode.
而且它简直——简直太棒了。它有棒极了的音乐。它有棒极了的氛围。我觉得，如果每个人都看了它，世界会变得更好。真的，它教会你关于生活和满足感。而且我只是——我觉得它超级美。我是说，是的，伴随着美妙的音乐清理东京的厕所，听起来就像是一集99PI。
It really, it feels like it, like it has a kind of an underlying kind of spiritualism that I sometimes feel with 99PI, like specifically like we would never do something so unstory-like as that one. It's more of like a mood. But it has just like appreciation of urban landscape, of ritual of care. You know, it has that feeling that I think people told me about the show. Like, I was, I don't know if I knew I was embedding it in the show in the very beginning, but this sort of sense that when you notice design details, you notice that you're being cared for by people. Like, you notice that things are being made better for you. And this is a movie that's just about that, about like somebody who's making the world better for other people and the, and himself and finding great contentment in that and contentment in the world. And it's just, it's just lovely. Like, you really should watch it. I think you would. like it and it has just the greatest soundtrack because he also like he listens he buys cassette tapes like use
真的，它给人的感觉是，它带有一种潜在的精神性，有时我在99PI中也能感受到这种精神性——具体来说，我们永远不会做像那一集那样完全不像故事的事情。它更像是一种情绪。但它恰恰欣赏城市景观、关怀的仪式。你知道的，它拥有那种人们向我提起这个节目时的感觉。就像，我不知道在最初的时候我是否知道自己将它融入了节目中，但这种感觉是：当你注意到设计的细节时，你会注意到你受到了人们的关怀。就像，你会注意到事情正在为你变得更好。而这部电影正是关于这一点的，关于某人为其他人以及为他自己让世界变得更好，并在其中以及在世界上找到巨大的满足感。而且它真的很可爱。真的，你真该看一看。我想你会
cassette tapes of like of um you know of velvet underground and stuff like that the music is you know is so good so it's great okay i promise i'm going to watch this one and i will post on our movie club uh slack channel as soon as i watch this sounds good um okay so the next question came from somebody here on staff uh at 99 p i who you will probably recognize hey roman uh this is joe you know me. Now that you're such an expert on con law, if you were allowed to make one serious change to the Constitution, what would it be? So that, of course, is our producer, Joe Rosenberg. I think you just have to eliminate the Electoral College. I think that's it. I mean, I think that everything good follows from that. That sort of weird proportional weight and sort of the tyranny of the minority and all that sort of stuff just goes away. I'd much rather have the tyranny of the majority than the tyranny of the minority. And a lot of the horrible stuff unwinds when you have the popular election of the president. I think it's a huge thing.
喜欢它的，而且它有着最棒的原声带，因为主角也听——他买磁带——使用过的磁带，比如地下丝绒（Velvet Underground）之类的音乐，音乐——你知道的——太棒了，所以棒极了。好的，我保证我会去看这部，而且我一看完就会发到我们的电影俱乐部Slack频道。听起来不错。好的，那么下一个问题来自99PI的某位内部员工，你可能会认出他：嘿，罗曼——这是乔，你认识我。既然你已经是宪法专家了，如果你被允许对宪法进行一项重大修改，那会是什么？所以，那当然是我们的制作人乔·罗森バーグ（Joe Rosenberg）。我觉得你必须废除选举人团制度。我想就是这个。我是说，我觉得所有美好的事物都由此而来。那种奇怪的比例权重、少数人的暴政以及所有诸如此类的东西就都消失了。我宁愿要多数人的暴政，也不要少数人的暴政。而且当你通过普选产生总统时，许多可怕的事情就会迎刃而解。我认为这是一件大事。
That's what I'd change first. Got it. So the next question is, what's a design-related hill you're willing to die on? I don't want to die on any hill. I don't think. I mean, mostly when it comes to certain design things or design movements, like, truly the answer is nothing. Like, I can be convinced by a good story or a good reason. for any ugly thing to exist or whatever, if it's really thoughtful and done right.
这就是我首先要改变的。明白了。所以下一个问题是：有什么关于设计的观点是你愿意为之死守的？我不想为任何观点死守。我觉得吧。我的意思是，主要谈到某些设计事情或设计运动时，真正的答案是：没有。任何丑陋的东西，只要它经过深思熟虑并且做得对，我都可以被一个好故事或好理由说服，觉得它有存在的合理性。
That was the whole premise of the show, is that I wanted people, if they couldn't see the ugly building, because we were doing this on the radio or in podcasting, that they could learn to love it before they learned to hate it by seeing it. You know what I mean? Like, so that. But the one that's sticking with me, and this is going to be kind of abstract, and I don't know if this is going to come off well, is that is the idea of, the march to make things more and more efficient makes the world a worse place. And I think that this in terms of advertising. Like the idea that we were going to efficiently measure how effective advertising was through clicks and eyeballs and stuff,
这就是整个节目的前提，我想让人们——如果他们看不到那栋丑陋的建筑，因为我们是在广播或播客中做节目的——能够在通过视觉看到它从而开始痛恨它之前，先学会去爱它。你知道我的意思吗？所以，但是一直萦绕在我心头、而且这可能有点抽象、我不知道这能否表达清楚的观点是：让事情变得越来越高效的步伐使世界变得更糟。我认为这体现在广告方面。比如我们通过点击量和浏览量等高效衡量广告效果的想法，
erased all of the extra money that made all the journalism and all the pop culture that you cared about in the 20th century. It made it all possible. the inefficiency of the advertising system made everything good in this world. Like, I think that the idea that you're trying to get things to be as efficient as possible is actually a terrible world-destroying idea. And all it does is like the most efficient restaurant is like a ghost kitchen that has no storefront because that's inefficient because it could be empty sometimes. And it's a ghost kitchen that just ships you a thing and has an underpaid delivery person
抹去了所有那些在20世纪为你所关心的所有新闻和流行文化提供资金支持的额外资金。正是这些让这一切成为可能。广告系统的不高效造就了这个世界上的所有美好事物。比如，我认为你试图让事情尽可能高效的想法其实是一个可怕的、毁灭世界的想法。它所做的一切就像是最有效率的餐馆是一个连店面都没有的“幽灵厨房”（ghost kitchen），因为有店面是低效的，因为它有时可能是空的。而且它是一个幽灵厨房，只把东西寄给你，并有一个薪酬过低的送货员
and brings it to your door and you never leave, and this is stripping away all the goodness of the world in the cities. Like, I think efficiency is absolute garbage, and that is the design-related hill I'm willing to die on. Like, I feel like you should always be allowing for great deals of inefficiency to make a nice design city, a nice design system, and make it work. I really hate the focus on efficiency. Not only does it, it destroys all these good things, it takes money, and gives it to the worst people, like the platform creators and the tech people, instead of all the loose, like, empty, like, change and tips and things. And it's not like things are cheaper or things are better. They just, money is being transferred to the wrong people instead of creators and people who make the world a better place through community and, and creation.
把它送到你门前，而你从不出门，这剥夺了城市中世界的所有美好。所以，我认为效率简直就是垃圾，这就是我愿意为之死守的关于设计的观点。我觉得你总是应该允许存在大量的不高效，从而打造一个设计精美的城市、一个设计精美的系统，并让它发挥作用。我真的很讨厌对效率的过分关注。它不仅摧毁了所有这些美好的东西，还把钱夺走，送给最糟糕的人，比如平台创造者和科技界人士，而不是留给所有零散的、空闲的零钱和小费以及其他东西。而且事情并没有变得更便宜或更好。只是钱被转移到了错误的人手中，而不是那些通过社群和创造力让世界变得更美好的人和创造者手中。
Yeah. A more efficient world is a place where more people are left out, essentially. Like, the more people are going to be more inefficient, the more people that are included. Yeah, totally. You need friction. You need the space of creation. That open freedom of an inefficient system where money sloshes around inside of it. Like, these frictions and inefficiencies are what make everything good about the world. Yeah. So if you can handle that big abstraction, that is the design-related hill. I'm willing to die on. I mean, that's a great spicy hill to die on. So I want to hear nothing about how good. efficiency is or the Department of Government efficiency. Non-sense. That is the worst world that we're building when we do efficient things. Yeah. Okay. Next question. So Gelsie Bennett on Instagram was wondering, when you were delivering pizzas in Memphis, a restaurant, were you delivering for?
是的。一个更高效的世界基本上是一个把更多人排除在外的世界。也就是说，越是效率低下，被包容进来的人就越多。是的，完全如此。你需要摩擦力。你需要创造的空间。一个资金在其中流动的低效系统的开放自由。这些摩擦和低效正是世界上一切美好事物的源泉。所以，如果你能理解这个宏大的抽象概念，这就是我愿意为之死守的关于设计的观点。我是说，这是一个很棒的、带劲的观点。所以我不想听到任何关于效率有多好或者什么政府效率部的废话。无稽之谈。当我们做那些高效的事情时，我们正在建设的是最糟糕的世界。好的。下一个问题。Instagram上的格尔西·贝内特（Gelsie Bennett）想知道：当你还在孟菲斯送披萨时，你是在哪家餐馆送的？
Okay. So my cousin, my beloved cousin, Lynn Ruther's, who passed away several years ago, was the manager, regional manager, of seven locations of Papa John's throughout Memphis. Wow. And so when I was extremely broke, I left grad school. I was moving out to San Francisco to do something. I didn't know what was going to happen. I delivered pizzas in her restaurants, and I would say, so I mostly worked out of the Bartlett location, that's kind of outside of Memphis. The big store was the Midtown store.
好的。所以我的表姐，我挚爱的表姐琳·鲁瑟斯（Lynn Ruther's）——她在几年前去世了——是孟菲斯各地七家棒约翰（Papa John's）分公司的经理、区域经理。哇。所以当我极其穷困潦倒时，我退出了研究生院。我正要搬去旧金山做点什么。我不知道会发生什么。我在她的餐馆里送披萨，我想说，我主要在巴特利（Bartlett）分店工作，那是孟菲斯郊外的一个地方。大店是中城（Midtown）店。
I worked there a little bit and lived in Midtown. So if you had Papa John's delivered to you in Midtown, but especially like Bartlett and Cordova, like kind of outside Memphis, like northern Memphis, you may have gotten a pizza from me. This would be in the mid-90s. You were a Papa John's guy then? I was a Papa John's guy. I mean, I was never a Papa John's guy, but that was the job that was offered to me.
我在那里工作了一小段时间，并住在中城。所以如果你曾在孟菲斯中城吃过棒约翰的外卖，尤其是像巴特利和科尔多瓦（Cordova）这样孟菲斯郊外、孟菲斯北部的地方，你可能吃过我送的披萨。这大概是在95年前后。你当时是棒约翰男孩？我是个棒约翰男孩。我是说，我从来不是什么棒约翰男孩，但那是分配给我的工作。
So in addition, if you grew up in Memphis in the 80s and 90s, I was. worked at a, my cousin Lynn owned a video store called Video Stop in Germantown, Tennessee. And you might have gotten movies rented by me. And this was when I was way underage. I worked there, like, all growing up. And then, and I worked at the Cecil's bagging groceries. So I worked a lot in Memphis during the summers and during breaks and stuff like that. And then at one point, I was talking with Chuck Bryant of stuff you should know who grew up in Germantown, Tennessee, and, and was a huge, you know, movie fan and ended up, you know, like moving out to Los Angeles to to work in movies before he started his podcast career. And we determined that he very likely
所以除此之外，如果你是在80和90年代在孟菲斯长大的，我曾在——我表姐琳在田纳西州日耳曼敦（Germantown）经营一家名为“录像带之停”（Video Stop）的录像带租赁店。你可能租过我经手的电影。那时我远远未成年。我在那里工作，伴随着成长。然后，我还曾在塞西尔（Cecil's）店装杂货。所以在孟菲斯的夏天和假期里我做过很多工作。后来，在某个时候，我和查克·布莱恩特（Chuck Bryant）交谈过——他是《你知道吗》（Stuff You Should Know）节目的主持人，在田纳西州日耳曼敦长大，是一个超级电影迷，后来搬到洛杉矶从事电影工作，然后才开始他的播客生涯。我们推断他极有可能是
was a customer at the video store that I was a clerk at. That's hilarious. Yeah. So side story, Jason DeLeon, who's one of the producers here at the show. But Jason used to do a lot of Brazilian jiu-jitsu and go to tournaments. And he's gone to a few in Southern California, and I, at one point, would be, like, a videographer for a jiu-jitsu competition. There's a chance that, like, I might have recorded Jason. Some type of Jason. Like, it's some kind of, like, hammer lock or something. That's awesome. I love it. Cool.
我曾当过店员的那家录像带租赁店的顾客。这太搞笑了。是的。顺便说一个插曲，杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon），他是节目的制作人之一。杰森过去常常练巴西柔术并参加比赛。他去过南加州的好几场比赛，而我曾一度担任柔术比赛的摄像师。有那么一种可能，我可能录下了杰森的视频。某种杰森的视频。就像是某种十字固（hammer lock）之类的。太棒了。我喜欢。酷。
Okay. So, our next question came from our Discord again, from a user named ASG-1982. And they ask, what goes into making a 9-9PI episode? Obviously, there's research in a script. But what are the steps of how it happens and where do all the background people fit in? It's kind of a big question. Yeah. Coming from a background person. Well, that's funny because I've always thought, well, background person is not how I would phrase our staff. One of the things I love about the show is I think that people have gotten to know all the producers and their personalities through the show.
好的。所以，我们的下一个问题再次来自我们的Discord，由一个名为ASG-1982的用户提出。他们问：制作一期99PI节目需要经历什么？显而易见，有研究和剧本。但它的具体步骤是什么样的？幕后人员都在哪里发挥作用？这算是个挺大的问题。是的。来自一个幕后人员的提问。嗯，这很有趣，因为我一直认为——“幕后人员”可不是我会用来称呼我们员工的词。我喜欢这个节目的原因之一是，我认为人们已经通过节目了解了所有的制作人和他们的个性。
I mean, definitely like I have a big imprint on the show. but I think a lot of people's taste and stuff comes out. But, like, what's really interesting is how much everyone works on every show in some way. So the process of putting together an episode, I think, is kind of around 16 weeks at this point. Like, that's how we count on it. They sometimes come in faster, but we don't count on them being much quicker than that. And a person pitches a story. It gets greenlit, and then they go report it for a while, just like find out stuff, interview people.
我的意思是，毫无疑问我在节目中留下了深刻的印记，但我觉得很多人的品味等等也展现出来了。而且，真正有趣的是每个人都在某种程度上参与了每一期节目的制作。所以制作一期节目的过程，我想目前大约是16周左右。是的，我们就是这样计算周期的。它们有时会更快完成，但我们不指望它们的节奏会比这快很多。一个人提出了一个故事构想。它获得批准，然后他们去进行一段时间的采访报道，就像去了解情况、采访人们一样。
They get assigned an editor, and that editor works with them to try to realize the sort of the potential of both what they're finding and what people desired in the pitch. And then it comes into form as a script that those two people mostly work on together. And then that's the first time I see it at that point is when it's a script and we do what we call a read to tape. but I think most people might know it as like a table read where essentially we just do it. We perform it live. And a bunch of people are in the room. I mean, this is all at Zoom. Used to be in one room, but now it's all on Zoom.
他们会被分配一位编辑，这位编辑与他们一起工作，试图实现他们所发现的内容以及人们在构想中所期望的潜力。然后它以剧本的形式呈现出来，这两个人主要一起在这个剧本上工作。在那之后，我第一次看到它的时候，它已经是一个剧本了，我们就会进行我们所说的“朗读录音”（read to tape），
And people put notes like in a Google Doc all along as like we're performing it and playing the tape that's been cut. And they're probably like, I don't know, when we're done, like hundreds. Hundreds of notes. Yeah, hundreds of comments. An overwhelming amount of comments. In a way, it's like a pretty brutal process, but everyone is really kind and everyone, I think, is like, we're trying to get to the best thing. And I think that everyone has like been trained to recognize that this is good. You know, like this is a good process.
但我猜大多数人可能更熟悉“围读剧本”（table read）这个词，本质上我们就是把它演出来。很多人都在房间里。我的意思是，这全部是通过Zoom进行的。以前是在同一个房间里，但现在全都在Zoom上了。当我们在表演并播放已经剪辑好的音频时，大家会在Google文档里随时写下各种笔记。我想可能——我不知道，当我们结束时，会有几百条。几百条笔记。是的，几百条评论。数量极其庞大的评论。从某种意义上说，这是一个相当残酷的过程，但每个人都真的很善良，而且我觉得每个人都认为——我们在努力做到最好。并且我觉得每个人都经过培训，认识到这是件好事。你知道的，这就像是一个好过程。
I've always liked our edits. I've been in other rooms or heard horror stories of other rooms about edits where people leave crying and stuff like that. That doesn't, I mean, people can leave frustrated because there's a lot of. lot to do and stuff like that. But we don't have a culture of cutting each other down here. No, no, no. We do have some brutal shorthands for things. Like, over time. So all the notes that come in and sometimes they're like, oh, I like this person or this like this like this, or we should move this part to here or whatever. But we have some short hands in the edit. So there's like somebody will put in CWGHF. Did I do that do that right? CW. G.H.
我一直很喜欢我们的编辑会议。我曾在其他房间参与过、或听到过关于其他编辑会议的恐怖故事，人们会在会上哭着离开等等。这倒没有——我的意思是，人们可能会带着沮丧离开，因为有很多事情要做之类的。但我们这里没有互相贬低的文化。不，不，不。我们确实对一些事情使用了一些极其简练的缩写。比如，随着时间推移。所有的笔记都被提出来，有时它们会说，哦，我喜欢这个人或那个，或者我们应该把这部分移到这里之类的。但我们在剪辑中确实有一些简写。比如有人会写上CWGHF。我没说错吧？CW.G.H.
Which is, can we get here faster? Yeah. Which is one of those ones for like, oh, like. Yeah. And it comes up in every single script. It's like, when is it going to happen? So can we get here faster is one. Oh, Emmett's, I love this one.
也就是：我们能更快切入正题吗？（Can we get here faster?）是的，这是诸如“哦，就像……”之类的话的缩写。是的，而且每个剧本里都会出现这种情况。就像是：什么时候能发生？所以“我们能更快切入正题吗”就是其中之一。哦，埃姆特的——我喜欢这个，
Relentlessly chronological is something that Emmett said once. Devastating, devastating comment. And it has to do with like these histories. Sometimes we do these long histories and you just feel like you're plotting along. it just captured something that I felt for a long time, but never put words to it. But that sort of sense of just like, oh, but if I skip from 900 AD to 1800, I have to put these like three things in between, but like you feel that they're unnecessary. And sometimes we just free ourselves from this idea. It's just like instead of being relentlessly chronological, just do the parts that are important and fun and for the story and stop being so relentlessly chronological. Like, sometimes the driving force of the action is time, and sometimes it's the thesis of the collection of things, so that you lead with that first.
“执着于按时间顺序列叙”（Relentlessly chronological）是埃姆特曾经说过的一句话。毁灭性的、毁灭性的评论。这与这些历史有关。有时我们做这些冗长的历史叙述，你会觉得自己只是在苦苦前行。它准确捕捉到了一种我感受了很久、却从未用言语表达出来的东西。但那种感觉就像是：哦，如果我从公元900年跳到1800年，我必须在这中间塞进这三件事，但你会觉得它们是不必要的。有时我们只是把自己从这种想法中解放出来。就像，与其执着于按时间顺序列叙，不如只做那些重要、有趣且对故事有益的部分，别再那么执着于按时间顺序列叙了。就像，有时行动的驱动力是时间，而有时是一堆事情的主旨，所以你首先呈现这一点。
And so it's a matter of mixing things up so you don't feel like you're just reading a timeline of events. So relentlessly chronological is a dig that kills me. Yeah. So, yeah, so then there's like that big long paper edit with lots of notes. Then there's the producer incorporates those notes and creates. It's an audio version of it. So, like, I'll get my script and I'll record my parts that record their parts and put it together. And that becomes what we call listen at it.
因此，这就需要把事情混搭起来，这样你就不会觉得自己只是在阅读一份事件的时间表。所以“执着于按时间顺序列叙”是一个一针见血的吐槽。是的。所以，是的，然后就会有那份带有大量笔记的长长的纸质编辑稿。接着，制作人会把这些笔记整合进去，并创建一个音频版本。所以，我会拿到我的剧本，录制我的部分，其他人录制他们的部分，然后把它们组合在一起。这就成了我们所说的“试听剪辑”（listen edit）。
And we listen to it all together as a sort of at least a first draft audio file and do the exact same thing. Put all the notes in here. And then those notes are incorporated into something called the notes mix. And those are, instead of us all getting together, we all kind of listen on our own and we put little notes in. Yeah, and then Martin mixes it. And then it comes out. And it really is like it's a long process and editing is a much bigger chunk of it than reporting, I would say. Yeah, for sure.
我们会把它作为一个初步的音频草稿一起听，然后做完全相同的事情——把所有的笔记都加进去。然后这些笔记被整合到一个叫做“笔记混音”（notes mix）的环节中。这一次不是我们大家聚在一起，而是我们各自聆听并记下小纸条。是的，然后马丁（Martin）对其进行混音。然后它就发布了。这确实是一个漫长的过程，而且我想说，编辑工作比采访报道要占去大得多的比重。是的，绝对的。
And so every story has been touched by, you know, like at least, you know, five or six people. Like, it's a big group effort. Like, it really takes a lot. Yeah, a story gets turned into soup multiple times over several weeks and it becomes a little episode butterfly by the end of it. It's a nice, gentle, but. all so scary process. Yeah, it's rigorous, but it's pretty gentle. Like most people who have done a tour through the show have commented on when they do this in other places. It's not so fun. I take real pride in that. A quick story. I do remember my first story was a freelance
所以每一个故事都经由——你知道的——至少五六个人的手。这是一个庞大的集体努力。这确实需要付出很多。是的，一个故事在数周内会被多次变成一锅杂烩，到了最后它就会变成一只小小的节目蝴蝶。这是一个不错、温和、但
story. And it was my first time ever doing an edit like that. And I came in through, I think it was the Zoom. And you, like, this was like an hour and a half into like a three hour process. You and Delaney were arguing, I think, about, like, Agent Orange or something, my internet dropped off. And I was gone for 10 minutes. And when I came back in, no one noticed I was gone. And you're still, like, arguing about Agent Orange. Well, there you go. More of your 15th anniversary questions after this. Okay, our next question is a voice message, and it's someone that you and I will recognize, but maybe some of the listeners have not heard their voice very much. So my question is, if you could commission any designer, living or dead, to create the ultimate piece of 99% invisible merch, like branded merchandise, what would that merch be?
又让人感到害怕的过程。是的，它很严厉，但也相当温和。大多数在节目中经历过一轮的人在其他地方做这件事时都会评论说：这可没那么好玩。我为此感到由衷的自豪。顺便讲个小故事。我确实记得我的第一个故事是一个自由职业的故事。那是我有生以来第一次做这样的编辑工作。我通过Zoom进来了。我想当时大概是三个小时流程进行到一个半小时的时候。你和德兰尼（Delaney）好像在争论关于橙剂（Agent Orange）之类的事情，我的网络掉线了。我消失了10分钟。当我重新进来时，没有人注意到我离开过。你们还在争论橙剂。好吧，就是这样。更多关于15周年的问题，广告之后继续。好的，我们的下一个问题是一条语音留言，提问者是你我都认识的人，但也许有些听众并没有怎么听过他们的声音。所以我的问题是：如果你可以委托任何设计师——无论在世还是已故——来创作终极的99%隐形周边商品，比如品牌周边，那会是什么周边？
and I ask this as someone who proudly owns and wears one of our brand new 99PI swimsuits. Well, that's Kelly Prime. That is Kelly Prime. Yeah, she doesn't show up on the show a lot, like her voice because she's an editor. But yeah, Kelly Prime is the greatest. Yeah, the funny thing about the swimsuit just as an assign
我问这个问题是以一个自豪地拥有并穿着我们全新的99PI泳衣的人的身份。哦，那是凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）。那是凯利·普莱姆。是的，她不怎么在节目中露面，因为她的声音听得少，因为她是一名编辑。不过是的，凯利·普莱姆太棒了。是的，关于泳衣有趣的一点是，作为一项任务
was this was presented to us because there's a big merch team at SiriusXM and they're just like, what about this? what about this? What about this? They just kind of like throw things at us. And they presented the idea of the 9-9PI swimsuit towels. And everyone was like, oh my God, what are you kidding me? That's ridiculous. And then they would go, but if you make them, can I have one? And so my wife did that. Vivian did that, almost exactly. I did that. And so we just did it because we're like, well, the people that will enjoy this will find it and fantastic um and so let's see the perfect merch i would love a like a deeter rams designed uh podcast player that really only pays a podcast i mean like the iPod was definitely based off of deer rom's like stuff with brawn like his his little miniature radio looks like
SiriusXM 的周边团队向我们提出了这个设想，他们当时就说：“这个怎么样？那个怎么样？这个呢？”他们总是向我们抛出各种想法。然后他们提出了 99PI 泳衣毛巾的想法。当时每个人都觉得：“哦天哪，你在开玩笑吧？太荒谬了。”但接着他们又会说：“不过如果你把它做出来，我能要一条吗？”于是我妻子就做了。薇薇安（Vivian）做了，几乎完全照做了。我做了。所以我们当时就觉得，既然喜欢这个的人会找到它，那就太棒了，所以让我们来看看完美的周边吧。我真希望能有一个由迪特·拉姆斯（Dieter Rams）设计的播客播放器，它真的只用来播放播客。我的意思是，iPod 绝对是以迪特·拉姆斯在博朗（Braun）的设计为基础的，比如他那个小巧的迷你收音机，看起来就像
a iPod like the first generation with the wheel and the white the white thing with the wheel So like a dedicated podcast player, you know, that... And just podcasts only. It's just podcast only, you know, maybe a little bit of a screen on it so you could see some stuff. You know, it'd have to be sort of Internet enabled. But yeah, I think something like that, like that would be the ultimate thing that I would probably enjoy and would be a nice 90% visible thing. And it's a very niche, very, like, not very widespread use device. rather than a real piece of merch.
一个 iPod，就像第一代带有转盘的那种，白色的，白色的转盘。所以是一个专用的播客播放器，你知道的……而且只能听播客。它真的只能听播客，你知道的，可能带有一个小屏幕，这样你可以看到一些内容。你知道，它必须具备联网功能。但是，是的，我觉得类似这样的东西，将是我可能会非常喜欢的终极产品，而且会是一个辨识度达到 90% 的好东西。这是一个非常小众、非常小范围使用的设备，
But, yeah, that's the kind of, that's the thing that comes to mind. For sure. Okay. So our next question, it's also a voice message, which I will just play for you here. Hey, Roman. It's frequent 99PI contributor, Gillian Jacobs. And if you were to create a show called 1% visible, what would it be about? Well, that's the same thing.
而不是真正意义上的常规周边。不过，是的，这就是那种我会想到的东西。肯定的。好的。那么我们的下一个问题，这也是一条语音消息，我这就把它放给你听。嗨，罗曼。我是《99%无形》的常驻撰稿人吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）。如果你要制作一档名为《1%可见》的节目，它会关于什么呢？嗯，这其实是一回事。
I mean, 99% invisible means 1% visible. So it would be the exact same show. Yeah, I mean, I think so. But I do it. This does bring to mind one thing. Like, we are, I've been thinking about, and we're sort of developing the idea of a show of a less abstract, more tactile kind of how stuff works quality of like, of describing infrastructure, of like, I touch a light switch, that wire goes to a wire that goes to a wire that goes to a transformer. That's really about you're interacting with how the world works in a, in less of a story way and more of just like, I just don't understand how that works. How does, you know, how does electricity come into my house?
我的意思是，“99%无形”就意味着“1%可见”。所以这将是完全相同的节目。是的，我的意思是，我也这么认为。但这也确实让我想起了一件事。比如，我们一直有在考虑，并且我们正在构思这样一个节目的想法：它具有一种较少抽象、更具触感、更偏向“事物是如何运作的”那种品质，比如去描述基础设施。就像我按下一个电灯开关，那根电线连接到另一根电线，再连接到另一根电线，最后连接到一个变压器。这其实更多是关于你如何与这个世界的运作方式进行互动，少了一些故事性，多了一些纯粹的“我只是不明白这东西是怎么运作的”。你知道的，电究竟是怎么进到我家里的？
That's what that feels like to me as an idea of 1% visible. And that's a thing that we're developing, and I think that would be worth doing, you know, as a 1% visible. Okay. So next question. If aliens visited Earth and you had to show them one designed object to explain human civilization, what would it be? Wow, that's a tall order. I don't know. I'm kind of obsessed with the – my go-to answer is the Golden Gate Bridge.
作为一个关于“1%可见”的想法，这就是它给我的感觉。这也是我们正在开发的一个主题，我觉得作为“1%可见”来做是很值得的。好的。那么下一个问题。如果有外星人访问地球，而你必须向他们展示一个设计物件来解释人类文明，那会是什么？哇，这可真是个难题。我不知道。我有点迷恋——我惯常的答案是金门大桥。
I just think it's super gorgeous. and I think it does, it looks like what it does. Like, it's design and physics and stuff is on display, and it's beautiful. And I don't know. That's probably my answer. There might be a deeper answer there, but I just love it. I love looking at it. It's a really good bridge.
我只是觉得它超级华丽。而且我认为它做到了“形如其职”。它的设计、物理原理等等都展露无遗，而且非常美观。我不知道。这大概就是我的答案。可能还有一个更深层的答案，但我就是喜欢它。我就是喜欢看着它。这是一座非常棒的桥。
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Next question. What is the most emotionally manipulative piece of design that people encounter daily without realizing it? I mean, the first thing that comes to mind is people really react to anything with faces or eyes. I mean, I would say, so I have a couple of things. The thing they react to are faces and eyes and they react to music.
是的。好的。下一个问题。人们在日常生活中不知不觉会遇到，最具情感操纵性的设计是什么？我的意思是，首先想到的就是人们对任何带有面孔或眼睛的东西反应非常强烈。我的意思是，我会说——所以我有一些看法。他们会强烈反应的东西就是面孔和眼睛，还有音乐。
And one of the things that, like, I love using music and storytelling because you can just, like, get people on board with something. you can you can like it's so manipulative in just the greatest way possible and I love using it you know all the time I love movies with good scores in them that are emotionally manipulative and then in terms of like faces and eyes like I know that there's like I think there was a study that if you put like eyeballs or some kind of human face on a tip jar or like people tipped more I think anything that has eyes or looks like somebody's watching you is probably the most emotionally manipulative stuff that sort of like gets you um yeah that that that you encounter on daily basis i mean and this is true like cute faces i mean if your kids weren't cute if your dog
其中有一点，比如我喜欢用音乐和讲故事，因为你只需这样就能让人们对某事产生共鸣。你可以……这在某种程度上具有极具操纵性，而且是以最棒的方式，我真的很喜欢一直使用它。我喜欢那些配乐出色的电影，它们具有情感操纵性。然后就面孔和眼睛而言，我知道有——我想曾有过这样一项研究：如果你在小费罐上放上眼珠或某种人类面孔，人们给的小费就会更多。我想任何有眼睛或看起来像有人在看着你的东西，大概都是最具情感操纵性的东西，它会在某种程度上吸引你……是的，你会每天都遇到这种情况。我的意思是，确实如此，比如可爱的面孔——我的意思是，如果你的孩子长得不那么可爱，如果你的狗
wasn't cute like they just they make you they're so i mean they're so adorable and they're so annoying and you would never endure them in other ways if they didn't have these just cute little faces and so that's the most emotionally manipulative thing i how people use it. Mostly, I think people use it in a benign way. And mostly it's like good that you love your children because they have cute faces. It's mostly good that you love your children. This does remind me of, you know, we get a lot of those like autonomous delivery carts here in Los Angeles. Yeah. And they have these like digital interfaces that have a, like an actual face on it that smiles. And it's just like, please don't murder me. I'm just trying to do my job. Don't knock me over. Don't steal me.
长得不那么可爱，它们只是……它们让你觉得它们太招人喜爱了，同时也太烦人了，如果它们没有这些可爱的小面孔，你绝对无法在其他方面容忍它们。所以这就是最具情感操纵性的东西，我是说人们是如何使用它的。大多数情况下，我认为人们是以一种温和的方式使用它的。而且大多数情况下，因为它们长着可爱的面孔而让你爱自己的孩子，这是一件好事。大多数情况下，爱自己的孩子是件好事。这确实让我想起了，你知道的，我们在洛杉矶这里看到了很多那种自动送货车。是的。它们上面有那种数字界面，上面有一个会微笑的真实面孔。那感觉就像是：“求求你别谋杀我。我只是在努力工作。别把我撞倒，别偷我。”
It's true. I think that's definitely why. those faces are there. I don't know if they work 100% of the time, but it's why they're there for sure. Okay. So next question. What's something you deeply believed about designer storytelling 15 years ago that you've now completely reversed your thinking on? Completely. Completely. I mean, I mean, the obvious one to me in terms of storytelling and storytelling about design is that, you know, I created what I thought was the thing that the world needed was this perfect little five-minute jewel of a story that was kind of like kind of a story, but more of like an opinion and had a few key facts and a, you know, like something that made me laugh and a, you know,
确实如此。我想这绝对就是这些面孔存在的原因。我不知道它们是不是百分之百起作用，但它们之所以存在，肯定就是为了这个。好的。那么下一个问题。关于设计或讲故事，你十五年前深信不疑，而现在已经完全改变看法的是什么？完全改变。完全改变。我的意思是，对我和讲故事以及关于设计的讲故事而言，最显而易见的改变就是，你知道的，我曾经创作了我认为世界所需要的东西——一个完美的小故事，只有五分钟的精美片段，它有点像个故事，但更像是一种观点，包含几个关键事实，还有能让我笑出来的内容，以及一个……
whatever. And never thought I would make a show like the power broker breakdown that is like three hours long of two dudes talking about. But I, um, but I, I loved making that show. So I've kind of turned around a lot on that. And I just learned that, like, a lot of my favorite podcasts are like that. And I just sort of forgave myself and gave myself the permission to create one on my own. It is funny that the lesson that you learned after 15 years of making a podcast is that you like podcasts. Okay.
诸如此类。而且我从未想过我会制作像《权力经纪人剖析》（The Power Broker Breakdown）这样的节目，那是两个家伙聊了三个小时的节目。但，呃，但我真的很喜欢制作那个节目。所以我对这方面的看法已经有了很大的转变。我只是了解到，很多我最喜欢的播客也是那样的。我只是原谅了自己，并允许自己去创作这样一个属于我自己的播客。真是有趣，你做了十五年播客之后学到的教训竟然是你喜欢播客。好的。
Yeah. So the next question is from me, because I'm curious if you will answer it. Okay. So, you know, there are a lot of design lessons that the show has tried to, you know, impart out in the world. Like, you know, buses are good. Cities that are walkable are great. So there's a lot of, like, positive design lessons that I think people take from our show. Do you think there are any design decisions that have been unfairly blamed on your influence?
好的。所以下一个问题是来自我自己的，因为我很好奇你是否会回答它。好的。你知道，节目一直试图向世界传达许多设计理念。比如，你知道的，公交车是好东西。适合步行城市是很棒的。所以我觉得人们从我们的节目中汲取了许多积极的设计理念。你认为是否有任何设计决定被不公平地归咎于你的影响力？
Okay. Well, I think I know where this is going, which is, I don't think unfairly blamed, but it does. definitely is blame. And I take some of it as being justified. So probably the biggest cultural reach mere the show has ever had was this 2015 TED talk about flag design. And where I sort of enumerated the North American Vexillological Association's principles of flag design as written down by Ted Kay, who was great. And I love this, it has this pamphlet called Good Flag, Bad Flag. I did an episode based off of it and talking to Ted as the sixth episode of this show.
好吧。我想我知道这是要指向哪里了，那就是，我不认为是“不公平地归咎”，但这确实构成了归咎。而且我认为其中一部分是情有可原的。所以，这档节目有史以来在文化上影响最深远的，大概就是 2015 年关于旗帜设计的 TED 演讲。在那场演讲中，我列举了北美旗帜学协会（North American Vexillological Association）的旗帜设计原则，这些原则是由泰德·凯（Ted Kay）记录下来的，他非常棒。我很喜欢这个，它有一本名为《好旗帜，坏旗帜》（Good Flag, Bad Flag）的小册子。我根据它做了一期节目，并且在节目的第六集中采访了泰德。
And then when I was approached to do a TED talk, I kind of had this idea of putting together like this big, grand theory of design with lots of different stories and stuff. And it wasn't really working. I was trying different parts of it live and it wasn't really working. but like this expanded flag talk was the one that was making people laugh and being fun and putting up pictures of flags and making fun of flags and stuff. And then using the design principles of flags to talk about design principles in general that they kind of work for almost everything.
后来当有人邀请我去做 TED 演讲时，我脑子里大致有这样一个想法：把这个宏大的设计宏观理论与许多不同的故事之类的内容结合起来。但这个构想当时并不太管用。我尝试在现场讲不同的部分，但效果并不理想。不过，这个扩展版的旗帜演讲却能逗笑大家，让人觉得很有趣，展示旗帜的图片，取笑各种旗帜之类的。然后利用旗帜的设计原则来谈论一般的设计原则，因为这些原则几乎适用于所有事物。
And the flag talk was really huge. Like it was bigger than I thought. Like when I went to TED conference, the former prime minister of Australia was there and who gave a talk and he was talking about normalizing trade relationships with China. or something and I was like oh my god in two days I want to do my dumb like flag talk and now I feel like such a loser you know and I did
而且那个关于旗帜的演讲真的反响巨大。比我想象的还要大。比如当我参加 TED 大会时，澳大利亚前总理也在那里，他发表了一演讲，谈论的是与中国实现贸易关系正常化之类的事情。当时我想：“哦天哪，两天后我要发表我那个愚蠢的旗帜演讲了，现在我觉得自己像个彻底的失败者。”你知道的。然后我做了
this talk and it was like totally a home run like people loved it there was like a standing ovation it was so much fun and the title of talk was it was eventually titled by TED as the worst design thing you've ever not noticed or something like that and it was about city flags and how city flags need to be better and I used
这个演讲，简直大获成功——人们非常喜欢它，全场起立鼓掌，真的太有趣了。那个演讲的标题后来被 TED 定为“你从未注意到过的最糟糕的设计事物”或者类似的名字，它是关于城市旗帜的，以及城市旗帜如何需要变得更好，我用了
lots of different examples and it being released into the world resulted in maybe I think at this point, 300 or more flag redesigns all around the world. And most of these flag redesigns are just like old. You know, they put the city seal on a blue field and they're just thoughtless flags, you know, and they've been redesigned without too much controversy. And the lesson of the whole thing was if you're in a city that doesn't fly a flag, it's probably because it violates these design principles. And a good way to get to the point where you have a flag that you're proud of is
许多不同的例子，而它被公之于众的结果是，我想到了这个时候，全世界大约有 300 个或更多的城市旗帜重新设计。而且这些旗帜的重新设计大多只是……你知道的，他们把城市徽章印在蓝色底面上，这些都只是不经大脑思考的旗帜，你知道的，它们在没有引起太多争议的情况下被重新设计了。整个事件的教训是：如果你所在的城市没有悬挂旗帜，那可能是因为它违反了这些设计原则。而要达到让你拥有一面引以为傲的旗帜的好方法，
is to use these design principles to create one, because it's this great symbol that nobody owns, that everyone can have city pride. And when you see it in action, like when you see it in Chicago, it's amazing. It's an amazing unifier that it's on the shoulders of police officers. It's on like hipster tattoos. It's on every type of business uses like the stars or stripes parts of the Chicago flag. And when it's not well designed like San Francisco, you barely see it anywhere. And the whole point was to love your flag, have a municipal symbol that nobody owns. And if your flag is bad, it probably violates these principles and maybe redesign it so it's a good one. But the key is love your flag. Use your flag. Like it's a resource that's wasted. Okay. And even there's a line at the end that I think people kind of missed, which is, which is I don't care if your flag is ugly. Like just use it. Like use it. Don't let it go to waste because otherwise sports teams and corporations, they take over the identity of a city. And so a lot of people redesign their flag, and I think mostly for the good. I never get involved in flag redesign, contest or flag redesign, like, drama.
就是利用这些设计原则来创作一面，因为这是一个无人拥有、每个人都能借此获得城市自豪感的伟大标志。当你看到它发挥作用时，比如你在芝加哥看到它时，那是相当惊艳的。它是一个了不起的凝聚剂，它印在警察的肩膀上。它印在各种嬉皮士的纹身上。各种类型的企业都在使用芝加哥市旗上的星星或条纹元素。而当它设计得不够好时，比如旧金山，你几乎到处都看不到它。核心的意义在于热爱你的旗帜，拥有一个无人拥有的市政标志。如果你的旗帜很糟糕，它可能就违反了这些原则，也许可以重新设计一下，让它变得好一些。但关键是热爱你的旗帜。使用你的旗帜。就像它是一种被浪费的资源一样。好的。甚至在结尾处还有一句话，我想大家可能有点忽略了，那就是——我不在乎你的旗帜是否丑陋。用起来就行了。就像是去用它。不要让它白白浪费，否则体育球队和企业就会接管一个城市的身份认同。所以很多人重新设计了他们的旗帜，我认为大多数都是朝好的方向发展的。我从来不参与旗帜的重新设计、比赛或旗帜重新设计的各种“抓马（戏剧性事件）”。
Like, my point was just to talk about it as a thing and have people do it, because people should choose what represents them. And using the principles, that's a good way to do it, to make a good one. Now, like anything where, like, you're sort of, like, putting a list of things to make things good or a certain, like, orthodoxy gets created. And in that orthodoxy, I think some of the redesigns have had a samey, same equality to them, you know. And it was not something that I imagined because I didn't really think it would have that big of an effect. But, but they, you know, especially my praise of the Chicago flag have led people to create like a lot of Chicago-y style flags instead of something like kind of cool and on their own. And actually, and violate those principles when they're meaningfully worth violating, you know, like the idea of, of, of, of two to three colors and like I love like for example the California flag it says California
我的观点只是把它作为一个事物来讨论，让人们去付诸实践，因为人们应该选择代表他们自己的东西。利用这些原则，这是一个好方法，能够设计出一面好旗帜。现在，就像任何事情一样，比如你列出一个让事情变好的清单，或者某种清规戒律被建立起来。而在这种清规戒律中，我认为有些重新设计呈现出了一种千篇一律的品质，你知道的。这不是我能想象到的，因为我真的没想到它会有这么大的影响。但是，它们——特别是由于我对芝加哥市旗的赞美，导致人们创造了许多芝加哥风格的旗帜，而不是那种很酷的、属于他们自己的东西。而且实际上，当有意义地值得违反这些原则时，却去违反了它们，你知道的，比如“两到三种颜色”的概念——我喜欢，举个例子，加利福尼亚州的州旗上面写着“加利福尼亚共和国”（California Republic），旗帜本应在两个方向上都能正常发挥作用，所以在上面写字就属于一面糟糕的旗帜，你知道我的意思吗，因为你从反方向看它时，它是反过来的。我不在乎，因为“加利福尼亚共和国”这个名字太能说明加利福尼亚和加州人了，它上面依然写着“加利福尼亚共和国”，我绝不会改变它。我还专门在 TED 网站上发布了一整份增补内容，列举了那些违反了这些原则但依然极其精彩的旗帜。比如写过这本书的泰德·凯也完全赞同这种做法，有思想的、你知道的——对规则的违反完全是其中的一部分。如果对规则盲目遵从到每样东西看起来都像是在一个非常简化、你知道的、插画类型的程序里制作出来的，那就失去了那些以不同方式涌现的旗帜所具有的快乐和活力。嗯，我觉得——就像任何设计清规戒律一样，任何事物上都有这种危险。所以我对此承担一些责任，我知道我是其中的煽动者，但我真的不是指每样东西看起来都应该那么无聊，整件事情的意义其实仅仅是让你拥有一件
Republic on it like a flag is supposed to work in two directions so having words on it is like a bad flag you know what you mean because you see it from the opposite direction so it's backwards I don't care California Republic is so it tells you so much about California and Californians that it still says California Republic on it I would never change it and and I put out a whole like addendum of like things you're like on the TED site of a flags that violate the principles but are still fantastic and like and Ted K who wrote you know the book on this like totally agrees with that type of stuff too like thoughtful you know like violation of the rules is totally part of it adhering so closely to the rules that everything kind of looks like it was made in a you know a very simplistic um you know illustrator type program and it doesn't have the joy and verve of some of these flags that came up in different ways um i i think that just like there's just a danger of any sort of like design orthodoxy on it on on anything and so so i take some blame for that like i know that i was the instigator in that but i really didn't mean everything should look boring like that was the whole point was just to have something that you
你所热爱的、因此愿意去高高飘扬的东西。我觉得这一点正是大家有点忽略的地方，所以我承担一部分责任。但我也认为，我的全部出发点就是做出一些很酷、很有趣、能让你因为热爱自己的故乡而想要去纹身的东西。你的旗帜是否完美并不重要。它应该以一种很酷的方式代表这座城市。这就是我所关乎的一切。公平地说，我认为很多受我们 TED 演讲启发而设计的旗帜，最终都比以前更好了。哦，我认为绝大多数都是这样的。我的意思是，我会说 90% 的都是如此。我只是觉得，我只是觉得偶尔会看到——尤其是因为他们经常举办设计比赛，老实说，我认为这是一种抹杀
love so that you flew it um and i that i think that was the part that was like a little bit missed so i take some blame but i also like think that um my whole point was to make something cool and fun that you would get a tattoo of because you just loved where you were from. And it doesn't matter if your flag is perfect or whatever. It just, it should be, it should represent the city in a cool way. That's, that's all I care about. And to be fair, I think a lot of, a lot of flags that were inspired by our TED Talk ended up better than they were before. Oh, I think the best majority did. Like, I would say that 90% of it did. I just think that, I just think that occasionally there's just like, you see, like, especially because they often do design contests, which I think is a way to flatten
创造力的方式。它确实带来了很多想法，但当人们对其进行投票时，他们会选择那种最温和、最像一面旗帜的方案。现在，人们对“什么才像一面旗帜”的理解已经变成了某种并不是超级鼓舞人心东西。你应该直接雇人来做一些很酷的设计，委任他们去完成，把它做好，然后推向大众。如果它更具冲击力或者诸如此类，那绝对是一件好事。你的城市应该是独一无二的。太棒了。好的。那这就是 15 个问题。哦，太好了。不过我这里还有一个彩蛋要送给你。
creativity, honestly. Like it brings in a lot of ideas, but then when people vote on it, they choose the one that is kind of the most anodyne, the most that feels like a flag. And now the idea of what feels like a flag has changed into like kind of something that isn't super inspiring. You should just hire someone to make something cool and the commission them and make it great and put it out there. And if it is a little more, I don't know, shocking or whatever, that's a good thing. Your city should be unique. Great. Okay. So that was 15 questions. Oh, good. But I also have a bonus here for you.
好的。又一条语音消息。我这就放给你听。这是来自德国的蒂娜（Tina）。我的问题是，罗曼的双胞胎现在过得怎么样？他们对自己在《99%无形》早期节目中客串出场有什么感受？这是一个好问题。双胞胎现在过得很棒。马斯洛（Maslow）和卡弗（Carver）马上就要上大学了。我确实问过他们是否可以说出他们要去哪所大学，他们说：“不行。”很机智。非常机智。但我觉得他们对自己在节目中所扮演的角色相当自豪。我的意思是，对于那些不知道、没有听过早期节目的听众来说，我们在最开始的时候，
Okay. Another voice message. I'm going to play it for you. This is Tina from Germany. And my questions are how Roman twins are doing and how they are feeling about their cameos in the early episodes of 99PI. That's a good question. The twins are doing great. Maslow and Carver are about to go to college. I did ask them if I could say where they're going to college, and they said, no. Smart. Very smart. But they, I think they're pretty proud of their role in the show. I mean, they were, for people who don't know who didn't listen to early stages, we, we, MailChimp was a sponsor in the very, very beginning. They had a product called Tiny Letter and their slogan was email for people with something to say. And my kids were very talkative from a very early age. And I thought it'd be
MailChimp 是我们的赞助商。他们有一款名为 Tiny Letter 的产品，他们的标语是“给有话要说的人的电子邮件”。我的孩子们从小就非常话多。我想，
funny if I just would say, hey, Maslow, what do you have to say? Oh, hey, Carver, what do you have to say? And honestly, this empire was built on the charm of those twins. If we didn't have that as a sponsor in the very beginning, I do not know if we would be here today. And so it was It was a huge part of the show. It made people tune in to the end to hear what they had to say. I think they're quite proud of their role. And when they stopped, I think it was okay for us to stop. But I think they were like a little bit like, you know, because it was like the company that just ended the product. And so there was nothing more to do. You know what I mean? And it took me a minute to describe to them that they didn't do anything wrong, that it was just that the thing got canceled. Wait, they thought it was their fault. They, you know, it was really Carver who was like, oh, and then, and I was like, but it was, you know, like, they just stopped doing the, they just stopped doing the ads and, and, and it's okay. And like, people, like, I still love them and, you know, the people still love them. And so getting that lesson to them was like, was like kind of a sad one. And, and I think today they're pretty proud of it. And just, just for comparison to, you know, how old were they when they first started doing the ads? Like, maybe four. Like, they were three when I started. and maybe three or four when the ads started running. And they ran for, you know, like a long time, like six or seven, six or seven years, something like that.
如果我直接说：“嘿，马斯洛，你有什么想说的吗？哦，嘿，卡弗，你有什么想说的吗？”会很有趣。老实说，这个播客帝国就是建立在双胞胎的魅力之上的。如果我们在最开始没有那个赞助商，我真不知道我们今天是否还能在这里。所以这是一个巨大的节目组成部分。它让人们一直听到最后，想听听他们说些什么。我想他们对自己的角色相当自豪。当他们不再出镜时，我觉得对我们来说停下来也是合适的。但我想他们当时有点……你知道的，因为那是那个公司刚好终止了这款产品。所以已经没有什么可做的了。你知道我的意思吗？我花了一会儿时间向他们解释，他们没有做错任何事，只是那个项目被取消了。等等，他们以为那是他们的错？他们，你知道的，当时确实是卡弗说：“哦，然后——”我接着说：“但那其实是，你知道的，他们只是不再投放广告了，而且，一切都很好。”就像人们——我依然爱他们，你知道的，大家也依然爱他们。所以把这个道理传达给他们，感觉像是一个有点悲伤的过程。而且，我想今天他们对此感到相当自豪。而且，仅仅为了做个对比，你知道的，他们刚开始做广告时有多大？大概四岁吧。我开始做的时候他们三岁，
I did go back in the archives and I did pull one. And so this is what Maslow used to sound like. Support for 99% Invisible is provided in part by tiny letter. Email for people with something to say. What do you have to say, Maslow? My favorite thing to talk about is robots and iron minceips and stuff. Robots and Iron Man Suites. I would subscribe to that newsletter.
当广告开始播出时大概三四岁。而且他们播出了，你知道的，很长时间，大约六、七年，六、七年左右，诸如此类。我确实去翻看了档案，并找出了一个片段。所以这就是马斯洛过去的声音。对《99%无形》的支持部分来自于 tiny letter。给有话要说的人的电子邮件。你有什么要说的，马斯洛？我最喜欢谈论的是机器人和钢铁侠套装之类的东西。机器人和钢铁侠套装。我会订阅那个简讯。
That makes me cry. Oh. They're so big now. They're so big. Yeah. Oh, my goodness. Yeah. Yeah.
这让我快哭了。哦。他们现在长得好大了。他们长得好大了。是的。哦，天哪。是的。是的。
I love my adult children. But like when you're a parent, like you miss those little voices. Like it's so sweet. But yeah. Yeah, I'm so excited for the people that they've grown up to be. They're the best. Right. I mean, I guess we're going to leave it on the note of you crying.
我爱我的成年孩子们。但作为父母，你会怀念那些小小的声音。真的太甜美了。不过，是的。是的，我为他们成长为这样的人感到无比兴奋。他们是最棒的。对。我的意思是，我想我们会在你哭泣的氛围中结束了。
Oh, my goodness. Oh, my goodness. Yeah, that's, that works for me. That works for me. Well, thank you so much, Roman. This has been really fun. Oh, my pleasure. I've really enjoyed it. Thank you so much. And thanks for all the thoughtful questions. I thought this was actually really, like, this was interesting for me too. Like, I'm really into it. Like, this was not bad. Thank you. All right. Yeah, take care everybody. Thank you. Thanks for listening. Maslow, what do you have to say?
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。好吧，这对我来说挺管用的。这对我来说很合适。好吧，非常感谢你，罗曼。这真的非常有趣。哦，这是我的荣幸。我真的很享受。非常感谢。也谢谢你所有深思熟虑的问题。我觉得这实际上真的很棒，对我来说也很有趣。我是说我真的很投入，这感觉真不赖。谢谢。好的。保重大家。谢谢。感谢收听。马斯洛，你有什么想说的？
I'm going to college as of recording this in just over a month. I'm currently planning to do art and writing. I, like you, are interested in a lot of different things to only my own fault, and I don't think I'll be able to find a job where I can research everything in the world. worlds. But, you know. Maybe you can. Well, maybe I'll find something. Carver, what do you have to say? I am planning to study physics and communications. I want to become a science communicator and talk about the things that I love and spread information and teach people. Kind of like what my dad does. Oh, I'm so touched. That's sweet. Okay, well, you know, like early on, the show did. I didn't have a lot of advertisers and the ads with you really was the first solid foundation for the financing of the show.
录制这段音频时，我将在一个多月后上大学。我目前的计划是主修艺术和写作。和你一样，我由于自身的缺点，对很多不同的事情都充满兴趣，而且我不认为我能找到一份能够研究世界上所有事物的工作。但是，你知道的。也许你能。好吧，也许我会找到什么的。卡弗，你有什么想说的？我计划学习物理和传播学。我想成为一名科学传播者，谈论我热爱的事物，传播信息并教导人们。有点像我爸爸做的那样。哦，我太感动了。太甜了。好吧，你知道的，早期的时候，节目并没有很多广告商，而有你们参与的广告真的是节目融资的第一块坚实基石。
So you basically paid for your own college education by doing tiny letter ads. Oh, wow. I mean, great. I can now tell people I put myself to college. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian and also by our wonderful listeners who submitted such thoughtful questions. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Kathy 2 is our executive producer.
所以你基本上是通过做 tiny letter 的广告来支付你自己的大学学费的。哦，哇。我的意思是，太棒了。我现在可以告诉别人我是自己供上大学的了。《99%无形》本周由薇薇安（Vivian）制作，同时也感谢我们伟大的听众们，他们提交了如此深思熟虑的问题。由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。
Kurt Colestead is the digital director. Flaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Christopher Rubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of Visible logo was created by, Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual
库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Colestead）是数字总监。弗兰尼·霍尔（Flaney Hall）是我们资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·鲁贝（Christopher Rubei）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉舍马·多恩（Lashemadon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason），以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部目前位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城区的潘多拉大楼，向北六个街区。你可以在所有常规的
social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode, 15 years of 99% invisible at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。上面有通往该服务器以及每一期往期节目的链接，这里有 15 年来的《99%无形》，网址是 99PI.org。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。